microsoft has agreed to acquire
activision blizzard for
68.7 billion dollars making this
acquisition the largest buyout in video
game history and that's not by any small
margins prior to this it was take two's
acquisition of zynga for 12.7 billion
which only happened a week ago if
microsoft's acquisition of zenimax
bethesda wasn't enough of a big deal
well then it's hard to imagine it
getting any bigger than this with
activision blizzard now coming into the
fold that makes microsoft the home to 34
developers so here's an updated list to
every major franchise in studio that
microsoft now owns let's start with the
new ones to the xbox family
activision which basically means call of
duty that's right call of duty and all
of its developers which are quite a few
including treyarch responsible for black
ops infinity ward which spearheads
modern warfare and war zone and sledge
hammer games the folks behind vanguard
in world war ii along with it that means
all of cod support studios like raven
software bnox entertainment radical
entertainment and high moon studios in
an interesting twist this also now means
crash bandicoot is under the microsoft
umbrella developer toys for bob makers
of the recent crash bandicoot 4 it's
about time and skylanders also making
spyro a microsoft property now oh and
tony hawk the tony hawk game franchise
has been a part of activision since its
conception in 1999. the recent remake of
one and two is developed by vicarious
visions which has since been made a
subsidiary studio of blizzard
now let's go on to the other part of
this acquisition which is blizzard which
now makes microsoft the adopt parents to
some of the biggest franchises in gaming
history we are talking warcraft diablo
starcraft overwatch hearthstone and lost
vikings this is especially fascinating
considering the emphasis some of these
games have in the esports realm
specifically overwatch this money-making
train doesn't start and end with console
and pc gaming but also mobile since
developer king is a juggernaut all its
own under the activision blizzard
acquisition with king microsoft will own
candy crush farm heroes saga diamond
diary saga and pet rescue for context
king was acquired by activision in 2015
for 5.9 billion dollars
so those are the major franchises and
studios now coming into the big old
house of microsoft but while we're at it
let's go over all the other stuff that
microsoft also now has in 2020 microsoft
surprised all of us with the acquisition
of zenimax bethesda softworks for 7.5
billion dollars and to think that number
was shocking here's what that brought
along with it bethesda games studios of
course developer of the mainline elder
scrolls games fallout and the highly
anticipated soon to come starfield
zenimax online developers of the elder
scrolls online tango gameworks makers of
the evil within and interestingly the
sony timed exclusive ghostwire tokyo id
software the devs responsible for doom
and quake arcane studios the folks
responsible for dishonored prey and the
playstation timed exclusive death loop
machine games or rather the nazi ass
kicking studio these are the folks that
revitalized wolfenstein back in 2014
with new order and are helming a new
indiana jones game and i know
possibly
at least assumably they're working on
wolfenstein three
um
that i mean i hope
that would be cool
for me
yeah there's also roundhouse studios but
as of this video what they're working on
is still the mystery
[Music]
then there's the og microsoft first
party devs the ones that microsoft's
been collecting and picking up over time
but don't be fooled there's some heavy
hitters here to bolster microsoft's
enormous catalog of first party ips so
of course there's 343 industries the all
things halo developer world's edge
they're the devs that oversee age of
empires the coalition the studio that
took over the gears of war franchise the
coalition recently worked with warner
brothers on the impressive matrix
awakens experience is a matrix game on
the way under the coalition microsoft
name
only speculation but i'm sure it'd be
cool compulsion games developers of we
happy few with something unannounced
cooking in the oven double fine
productions the creative minds behind
psychonauts 2 broken age and brutal
legend the initiative what was simply
rumored as microsoft's big quadruple a
gaming studio is officially working on
the next perfect dark game then there's
in exile the developer of the wasteland
series mode jang studio aka the
minecraft studio one of microsoft's also
lofty acquisitions a few years back for
the now seemingly modest looking but
still by no means cheap in any regard
2.5 billion dollars ninja theory the
folks responsible for hellblade and its
upcoming sequel senwa's saga hellblade
2. they also did bleeding edge and are
working on the experimental game project
mara obsidian the role playing does
we're talking the outer worlds fallout
new vegas pillars of eternity grounded
and the upcoming avowed as well as the
outer worlds ii playground games the
forza horizon devs but in an interesting
twist they're also helming the upcoming
fable reboot speaking of forza there's
turn 10 who oversee forza motorsport
then there's rare these video game
veterans are responsible for sea of
thieves banjo-kazooie and the upcoming
ever wild lastly is state of decay
developer undead labs who are currently
working on state of decay 3. so
yeah that's
a lot those are 34 studios and the many
many big old franchises that are now
under the microsoft name
but back to the activision thing aside
from the games what does this mean for
the future of activision's leadership
microsoft is buying activision blizzard
at the height of a lawsuit filed by the
california department of fair employment
and housing against the company for
sexual harassment and discrimination
directed towards women at the company
with much of the tension falling on the
shoulders of activision's ceo bobby
kotick until this deal closes in 2023
activision blizzard will operate
independently but after bobby kotick is
expected to leave the company with
activision blizzard reporting to phil
spenzer as the ceo of microsoft gaming
this is a meaningful shift in the
perception of the company's leadership
and values which will hopefully have a
needed ripple effect across the culture
of activision blizzard nonetheless the
lawsuit continues with the intention of
an 18 million dollar settlement to
compensate and make amends to eligible
claimants there are still many many
questions however like what this deal
means for exclusivity will juggernaut
franchises like call of duty only be
where game pass is available on the flip
side however microsoft continues to
support minecraft with regular updates
across multiple platforms so
it looks like time will tell after all
we still haven't seen the full effects
of the microsoft bethesda acquisition
bethesda games like death loop and
ghostwire tokyo are still ps5 exclusives
at the moment then there's the case of
psychonauts 2 which was multi-platform
now of course that was abiding a
contractual obligation before the
acquisition with microsoft but
nonetheless it's something to think
about
alright thanks for watching for
everything news related with games
stay here at gamespot the place that
talks about games
a lot because it's in our name gamespot
okay bye
[Music]